je n'ai pas eu un repas décent depuis ces
demi-sangs que vous avez apportés et cette
toison stupide est censée seders voyez-vous
ces seders ici
cette faim rend ma vue pire
je pourrais juste vous prendre
si vous n'étiez pas un cyclope
pourquoi êtes-vous  tu portes une robe je passe une
très mauvaise journée hé hé hé
ne laisse pas ça devenir viral désolé il n'y a
tout simplement pas moyen que les autres enfants me croient
regarde c'est le déguisement que je montre
ici et pas une petite
quantité  de jambe drôle
j'essayais de rester non mangé assez longtemps
pour comprendre comment lui retirer la
toison alors
pensez-vous que je serais toujours habillé comme
ça si je le faisais
c'est une bonne chance